romney ray making his first start
against the cleveland indians yeah 21st
start of the season
first tier at rogers center as the blue
jay sparkling numbers for robby
opponents hitting just 215 against him
he's got that era down to
304 you mentioned that last start
against the boston red sox
it was a seven inning game because it
was game one of a double header
robbie pitched six of those and only
gave up one earned run
out number one and ahmed rosario will be
the banner
and there's a ball roped into left field
that's going to get down and go to the
wall
ahmed rosario on his way to second base
and that will be his 17th double of the
year he's turning into a double machine
and the indians have runners at first
and second one down fan mail reyes the
indians dh to the plate
there go the runner and ball is grounded
and they stay out of a double play
demar logo put the runners in motion and
that keeps them out of an inning ending
double play all they can get
is the runner at first base so the
runners move up now it's second and
third with two outs
harold ramirez the batter ground ball
back as robbie ray knocks it down
and ramirez is in a heap at home plate
as he fell on the swing and an inning
ending play as the indians strand a pair
eli morgan will be our northeast ohio
four dealers starting
pitcher this afternoon in toronto and
this will be his second uh start against
the jays made his first major league
start against him he got roughed up a
little bit in some bad weather but
uh he has an idea he's settling in he's
gonna have to utilize that fastball
again today
and he struck him out great breaking
ball by eli morgan
springer went down to a knee and that's
out number one and right on cue
the chance of mvp start to rain upon the
shoulders of vladimir guerrero jr
there's a liner in the center and that's
going to get down in front of miles
strong so just like that blatty guerrero
extends his hit streak to nine in a row
here's the d.a chain cleanup hitter now
bull buchet
high pop if she'll get him out of the
inning mile straw in center field
puts it away no runs a hit one left
after an inning no score
in toronto and here is their big gun
jose ramirez with two on and nobody out
pop-up
on the infield marcus sibi in the
shortstop right on the edge of the dirt
makes the cat that's a huge out retiring
jose ramirez
so now they're loaded up and harold
ramirez is the batter
after the second walk drive right field
base hit that'll score straw
here comes amanda rosario from the play
it is
in time they got him really good throw
by grichik
with rosario's speed i certainly
understand the decision to send him
right there
it's two down for oscar mercado oscar
lines one in the left field
base hit big friend meal coming around
third here's the throw and it's a
lollipop nowhere near
close and now the runners are both
advanced because ray was a little
tardy backing it up and now it's a two
nothing indians lead and you've got
runners at second and third with two
down
two more runners in scoring position for
owen
miller he jams miller and that's a soft
liner to second
the inning is over but the cleveland
indians
score the first two runs of the game
alejandro kirk the right-handed hitting
catcher
swing and a miss he's got his third
strikeout one away
and here's vlad guerrero jr
a little squib shot towards second and
the inning is over really good start for
eli morgan through three it's cleveland
two
toronto nothing nothing austin hedges
will lead it off
called strike three hedges didn't agree
with it and he's telling the umpire
damn bolina that's down yeah he'll walk
back to the dugout but he certainly let
the umpire know he thought it was low
for a ball back to the top of the other
mile straw
and there's another liner but this one
right to vladi guerrero at first
so robbie ray is out of the fourth
marcus semi leads off the fourth for
toronto line drive left field coming
hard is ramirez and he goes into the
slide and makes the catch
for out number one nice play comes
sliding in
boba shut the batter swing and a miss
heat goes
down heck and that's strikeout number
four for eli morgan
tay oscar hernandez the batter the o2
fastball blew it by him and how about
eli morgan
retires the side in order back to back
strikeouts he's punched out five
cutters back in third one out fran mill
reyes is the batter one and two
cut on and missed he went after that
higher fastball then robbie ray gets
another strikeout that's just his second
but it comes at a big time not out of
the woods yet harold ramirez steps in
here's the 3-2 pitch cut out and miss
robbie ray strikes out harold ramirez
with the high
fastball will go to the bottom of the
fifth eli morgan with a beauty going
working on a two-hit
shutout he took a fastball
and it was right there that's six
strikeouts for morgan here's santiago
espinal
swing and a miss and that's number seven
for eli morgan
four straight so kirk doubles now the
number nine hitter kevin biggio will
step in
punched him out with a fastball on the
inside corner
eighth strike out of the game for eli
morgan oh
miller the first baseman no balls and
two strikes
swung on and missed a nasty slider as
ray
strikes out miller that's his fourth
strike out of the afternoon
robbie ray over 100 pitches for the
ninth
time in 21 starts and there's pop-up
this is playable center of the diamond
simeon the shortstop takes charge and
pops it up robbie ray
six solid innings and that brings in
vladimir guerrero jr
with the tying run swinging intro
stay fair bow and go
plenty guerrero a bullet into the seats
and just like that
the blue jays have tied it base hit for
springer line drive into the seats home
run number 34 for vladi and we're
tied up with one swing of the bat and
he's sporting the home run jacket once
again
here's randall grichik hill band with
two down a runner on swing and a miss he
stayed off the plate grichik finally
gave in
and eli morgan with his ninth strikeout
of the day
a two-out walk and now you have to face
the lead-off man george springer
in the air mercado coming in from right
field makes the catch
seven of the books we're still tied to
so the blue jays have added four bullpen
arms in the last month and the latest a
deadline acquisition joaquim soria about
to make his toronto debut
two outs were in a top of the eighth
oscar mercado
good curveball how about a debut for
joachim sorya
in a 2-2 game he retires aside in order
with his strikeout
and here's bo bashetto for three the
cleanup hitter and today the dh
beats it into the ground quick flip
there's one
and they turn to double play to end the
inning
go ahead run stands at second we're in
the ninth tied at two
the pitch to mile straw
line drive to right miranda makes a
catch
what a break by randall grichik he broke
on
contact and makes a sliding catch to
take a hit away from miles strong
and now brian shaw tries to send it into
extra innings
to oscar hernandez facing sean here's
the set in the pitch
and it's swung on and driven toward the
gap in deep right center straw racing
back
sliding catch made as he got to the
warning track
miles straw showing you why the indians
acquired him at the deadline a game
changer defensively
and now alejandro kirk could win it here
backed up on a man kirk swung right
through it we've got
extra innings north of the border so now
the go-ahead run
is at third with nobody out amanda
rosario
at the plate smashed into left field of
ace hit and the indians take the lead
three to two and that's rbi number 30
for rosario in his
third hit of the ball game and that'll
bring up jose ramirez
ramirez will swing it right-handed now
the pitch
and it's swung on this is belted deep
left field if it's fair forget it
it is gone off the foul screen
and the indians get a two-run homer down
the left-field line
by jose ramirez and a three-run outburst
in the 10th
against former indian brad hand springer
is out number two and now vlad guerrero
jr
the last blue jay hope right back to him
he knocks it down and clausee will throw
him out to end the ball game so the
indians come to toronto and they go
ten innings to win it by a final of five
to two